made three huge baskets when they needed  it  if i told you a hawks uh first round  draft pick would have had a big impact  from the 18 draft you'd probably thought  maybe trey young would be that guy he  was kevin  tonight he was also a first rounder in  that draft  19th pick overall young of course that  famous trade from the mavericks to the  hawks  for luka doncic and the pick the  following year which turned into cam  reddish  not only their hawks moving on the  future plan now but they have  such great young talent all playing  in the playoffs for the first time and  rising to the challenge  and is trae young looking for his dad  maybe on this father's day he sure is  rayford proud papa right there that is a  happy father's day if there ever was one  trey young with 21 points 10 assists  was big in the fourth let's send it down  to stephanie reddy  she's got kevin hurder